back bad visa ban of course the world is
very excited to see these films but
Bennett sounds like your son is a very
excited cuz how cool his dad is Batman
like how would he for yes he's four he's
four years old so does he kind of think
you are
he actually nine kind of he believes
that I'm Batman
I've kind of set us sort of a trap for
myself because I showed him some of the
clips and the stuff and I told him yeah
you know I'm Batman and so now he thinks
like his dad is Batman now when I go out
of the houses are you going to the
Batcave I have to tell ya but going to
the Batcave I'm sure that you know it's
gonna come back to haunt me when he's in
therapy Batman
you do clay uh what sitting with the UPS
guy he's it's not the UPS it's the FedEx
guy you know I don't know if in this
country Federal Express has the same
color combination there's a sort of
purplish tint uniform but in the United
States they have this purple color and
so he thinks my son thinks the FedEx guy
is the Joker so every time he comes to
deliver a screenplay my son tells me you
know the dad Joker's outside and even
then he wants me to go fight him I have
to go through this little ritual where I
go out I give the guy twenty dollars to
do like a pantomime kung-fu Adam West
fight at me so my son will still believe
I'm Batman and I can beat up the Joker I
think the guys draw lots to not have to
deliver
but didn't you give it the best birthday
party though I did he wanted to have a
superhero party you know and that's
usually where you you know you you pay
some guys who dress up like on Hollywood
Boulevard has various superheroes and
they come and do pantomime a thing and I
said sure no problem he said dad I want
you to be real Batman I said ok I'll be
real Batman and I called the studio and
asked them if they would give me the
real costume and they sent costumers
over and I and it was 10:00 in the
morning you know it was really hot and I
put the outfit on it was broad daylight
and you know Batman's sexy at night he's
not that cool and 10 in the morning when
you're sweaty and hot and I was prepared
for it we're thinking it was a lot of
little kids but then I realized they all
brought their parents and so sort of
like being on this show and broad
daylight in my Batman outfit my scary
voice I came trundling out there I
walked out less other look on all these
adults faces kind of going wow
those thing he's gotten been bad and you
know I was 24 years old I mean I barely
knew anything at all and he does some
like lines sure sure sure
if you